hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben zuschauer ich glaube so ziemlich
jeder von euch hat es mitbekommen vor
einigen tagen wurde das neue iphone 11
vorgestellt und wir denke ich auch wisst
bin ich eigentlich relativ großer fan
von apple und fern von den produkten die
sie raus bringen allerdings haben sie
mich die letzten jahre wirklich sehr
krass enttäuscht das habe ich
zwischendurch immer mal auf dem pixel
umgestiegen bin und jetzt wurde halt das
iphone 11 vorgestellt und ich dachte mir
die werden dass eine von elf locker so
über krass macht und weil von allen
anderen seiten zusammen so einem google
etc haben kranke innovationen ihres
smartphones rein und dann kam die
pressekonferenz beziehen wir also dieses
apple event und es lief quasi so ab erst
mal
es wurde ein schnellerer prozessor
vorgestellt dann ein geringerer preis
zudem auch noch was hier jetzt bei dem
ihm gar nicht angezeigt wurde auch ein
größerer akku doch dann wird noch das
kamera design vorgestellt und ihr seht
schon im vergleich zu den prozessor und
dem preis und dem akku der jetzt hier
nicht unbedingt angezeigt wird das
kamera design schon so ein bisschen
veräppelt worden weil es ist allerdings
eventuell überhaupt nicht mitbekommen
haben sollte wie das neue iphone 11 pro
außerdem wird so dass das ist
tatsächlich die kamera und von diesem
design des iphone 11 programmen so
unfassbar viele - den letzten tagen ins
internet deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
hey ich warte ein paar tage sammeln paar
zusammen und mache dann heute eine
reaktion auf die lustigsten iphone elf
promis loske als allererstes erst mal
ein bild von einem produkt an dass ich
direkt denken musste als ich das iphone
11 pro design gesehen habe und was ist
das hier
ein 33 kommt rasierer ich meine es das
ist das erste was mir in den sinn
gekommen war als ich diese drei kameras
gesehen aber auch thema handy das sich
allerdings auch sehr viele user gedacht
haben die das apple event verfolgt haben
war dass das iphone 11 pro so aussieht
wie ein herd und hier wurde einfach ein
topf drauf gefordert stoppt während der
pressekonferenz und hier wird einfach
eine fahne draufgesetzt
neben den vergleichen das iphone 11 pro
mit dem rasierer und mit dem herd kam
selbstverständlich auch noch andere
vergleiche online auf verschiedenen
seiten unter anderem auch das hier das
ist nicht das einfach auf probe sondern
das normale iphone 11 das hat nur zwei
kameras allerdings mit dem blitz hält
wirklich aus wie das pikachu an wo das
iphone 11 pro ebenfalls mit einer
bowlingkugel verglichen
also ich muss wirklich sagen ich habe
als ich das event gesehen haben nur an
einen rasierer gedacht
aber dass leute eine politik google
denken oder auch hier keine verdammte
kokosnuss hey was haben leute für eine
kranke kreativität das nächste mihm
handelt einerseits auch davon hey womit
könnte man das iphone 11 pro vergleichen
also wem oder was sieht es ähnlich aber
andererseits ist auch so eine art person
you also wie sieht man aus wenn man mit
dem iphone 11 pro ein foto macht ich
kann euch sagen man sieht in etwa so aus
als schwarzenegger der einen
raketenwerfer in der hand hält noch
langeweile haben leute im internet etwas
was sich bei der ganzen kamera frage
allerdings allgemein wahl stellen muss
ist wofür braucht man diese drei kameras
überhaupt ich meine bei dem apple event
wurde irgendwie so gesagt hey wir haben
ein weitwinkel kamera also richtig
weitwinkel so dass man von übels weiter
dass man wenn man etwas übels nadal die
ich kann noch mal von vorne luca meine
kamera seine normale kamera also für
beispielsweise porträtaufnahmen oder
normale fotos dann gibt es eine
weitwinkel kamera also wenn man nahe an
einem objekt daran ist dass es trotzdem
so aussieht dass man eine menge drauf
bekommt das war auch noch nicht so gut
erklärt aber die kameras noch dabei und
noch eine ultra weitwinkel kamera so
dass man noch mehr sieht also quasi so
geführt wie wenn hier mein finger ist
und ich fotografiere den finger von hier
dass mein ganzes leben mit drauf ist was
im internet allerdings vermutet wurde
war dass die drei kameras ist ein von 11
pro hierfür das und zwar das einmal die
crm zugucken kann dann dass das fbi
einem zu gucken kann und noch homeland
security ja klar es ist lustig aber ich
meine an der stelle muss man sich halt
wirklich mal mittlerweile fragen also
ich weiß nicht ob das so bei mir so ist
aber zum beispiel letztens ich habe mit
meinem kumpel telefoniert und haben uns
darüber unterhalten haye am wochenende
ist ja fußball vielleicht hingehen hat
es noch karten
ich habe keine karte nicht aber auch
keine karten mehr bleibt ist die
gelabert aufgelegt ende
zwei stunden später war ich auf facebook
und habe werbung für trivago dafür nicht
vage für eventim oder für
ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau welche
plattform ist wahr oder welcher ticket
anbieter aber auf jeden fall eine
werbung für das spiel so von wegen hey
du brauchst doch tickets wir haben sie
hier zwar im doppelten preis aber dann
kannst du wenigstens sehen und da denke
ich mir einfach so ich habe kein mal
nach tickets gebucht ich habe lediglich
beim telefonat mit einem kumpel darüber
gesprochen und was ich auch so krass
komisch finde ist das handy heute die
ganze zeit zu mir wenn ich
beispielsweise sage hey simi dann geht
mein iphone an
das heißt er hat die ganze zeit mit die
ganze zeit wird irgendwie das handy mit
und weiß was ich erzähle von daher haye
klar ist es irgendwie cool weil dann
bekomme ich personalisierte anzeigen und
werbung kann mir besser gestaltet er
dabei ist es halt auch so was von hart
core creepy ich weiß nicht ob ich selbst
einfach zu kranker paranoid mittlerweile
geworden bin oder wie das ganze sehen
das könnt ihr mir gerne in die
kommentare schreiben allerdings finde
ich auch dass nicht nur das mikro
sondern auch die kamera gerade wenn
jetzt eine weitwinkel kamera dazu kommt
wer die noch mal mehr sehen kann um das
handy rum
das macht mir auch wieder mehr angst im
sinne von überwachungsstaat und bla bla
bla bla bla schwede was nein und ich
mein allgemeinen wenn wir uns die von
kameras bei hier angucken hier 2013 eine
kamera 2016 2009/10 jetzt drei 2002 und
aufs iphone bezogen
das ist das iphone elf sieht janson auf
iphone 111 pause aber wieder scheiße den
latte macchiato cappuccino mit
schokostückchen
also das ist wirklich mensch nicht
gesenkt ziemlich abstoßend allerdings
geht es bei der iphone 11 pro kamera
nicht nur um diese drei vorderen kameras
von wegen hey du kannst das handy so
nehme dann kannst du irgendwie krasse
ultraweitwinkel machen blabla sondern
die haben wir noch eine neue funktion
auf der innen kamera eingefügt und zwar
slow food service als video in slow
motion
ich habe mich als folge statt
wirklich froh dass gefragt mehere anyone
es vossloh vieh und ich meine wie sieht
es denn dann auswendig selbst ihren
dienst auf die macher oder so von mir
dann sieht ja aus wie das hier ein
faultier oder but also ich meine ich
will jetzt nicht rüberkommen die der
größte apple hält oder irgendwie sowas
mich da aber das versteht ja auch es
geht hier lediglich um den humor nicht
würde ich auch nur die minuszeichen die
leute gemacht haben und was übrigens
auch leute gemacht haben ist dass sie
sich jetzt schon ein iphone 11 pro
selbst gemacht haben zum beispiel das
hier ist einfach ein iphone 5 weil sich
einfach zwei kameras dazu gemalt hat
oder hier
er hat einfach einen taschenrechner
genommen apple logo drauf geklebt und
widgets bin hat er genauso aus wie die
drei kameras die ganzen teams haben wir
einfach wieder wagen zeigen apple
ihr habt das design mal wieder verpackt
und das internet ist ein hammer ort
anders hätte ich das heute wieder jetzt
allerdings auf ende meine lieben freunde
wenn euch meine reaktion hierauf diese
iphone elf promis gefallen hat das
unbedingt einen daumen hoch unter dem
video ihr da schreibt mir mal in die
kommentare
wie ihr über die ganze situation von
wegen kamera und mikrofon abhören et
cetera denkt habt ihr da auch so angst
wie ich abonniert zudem gern meinen
kanal falls sie bock auf mehr solcher
videos hat das ist kostenlos und die
verpasste videos nicht mehr und jetzt
lege ich mich wieder zu betteln ich bin
immer noch erkältet
[Musik]